let's talk there's so much to talk about
you've been on the show several times
and I've learned a lot okay thank you
you talked a lot in the past about men's
sexual issues that's been the focus
mostly the times you've been on I
thought today we would mix it up a
little bit what is it that women
complain about the most when they're
talking about their sexual complaints I
say we have talked about women one time
if you remember I said that low sexual
desire is one of the most common
problems that women have and I told you
that taking out the trash and helping at
home would help to increase your wife's
libido yeah I didn't do anything yeah no
I wasn't listening during that part yeah
well the second most common complaint
that women have is difficulty achieving
orgasm difficulty achieving women
complained that's that's a big complaint
achieving orgasm achieve the ability to
achieve orgasm the intensity of orgasm
and the ease and facility of reaching
orgasm so I mean okay I just you know
this raises a lot of questions there's a
bunch of stuff over here that they put
out on a tray during the commercial
break a bunch of implements I don't know
what these are it looks like you're
either gonna make a cake or talk about
sex well let's get into it what is this
just in the event that someone you know
may be having difficulty reaching orgasm
and even if they're not in between I
mean this using erotic toys is not
something that we need to do in secret
anymore and that's something that we
need to be ashamed of and they can also
be incorporated into the relationship
but shouldn't be doing it on the bus
yeah I know that's what I was thinking
oh yeah that's not a yeah this is
actually really unique and I'm really
excited about this one because this I've
actually done a study with this because
this this is called the womanizer and I
just want to show you how it works and
you how would it work on me if it's well
you'll see this could be applied to the
underside of the penis actually now that
you mention it I'm thinking but okay
feel that
feeling a vibrating sensation yeah and a
little bit of like a little bit of it
okay all right this was just my penis it
doesn't need to be up here now you know
it's been one place let's keep it in
that area all right little bits of air
go in and out is that right this is a
this is unique because of the pleasure
airflow technology patented by the way
so it actually sucks and pulls on the
clitoris mimicking oral sex it's not a
traditional mechanical wheel that spins
its air that sucks and pulls that's
exciting how much I'd pay as much as
$99.99 well they speaking of that look
they even have a lipstick version of it
what wait a minute what happened there
explain what happened there that just
looks like lipstick yeah well this looks
like Chanel perfume actually but yeah
but so look so this could be time to put
on my horse lips day I know it's it's
ridiculously it doesn't look anything
like mmm pleasurable that's not doing
anything that's pretty intense you can I
feel nothing I just know I'm not a
sexual being anymore that's well can you
help me
[Applause]
what have we done here Andy try a little
of that put that on putting this no no
you gotta put it on all right glitter
the man's ultimate pleasure center oh I
see yeah so it's the answers litoris is
located in the palm of his hand
apparently it's like a little mechanical
a little mechanical sucking mouth yeah
and pulling yeah okay I think the police
are gonna be here any second you better
put your stuff back in the van and get
out of here
you